Alright. Today we settle the cloud strategy. Marc, you've done the analysis — walk us through it.
Sure. I evaluated three paths: AWS only, GCP only, and multi-cloud from the start. My recommendation is single-cloud AWS.
AWS ecosystem is mature, our engineers know it, and managed service coverage is unmatched. ECS for containers, RDS for Postgres, S3 for storage. Boring stack, high reliability.
What about vendor lock-in? That comes up every time we do a pricing review with the board.
Lock-in is real but overrated at our scale. We're twelve people. Abstracting across two clouds costs more than the lock-in risk. We'd need a dedicated platform team to manage multi-cloud. We don't have that and won't for at least two years.
I agree with that logic. Multi-cloud is a tax we cannot afford right now. What does AWS-only actually mean for our stack day one?
EC2 or ECS for compute, RDS for Postgres, S3 for storage, CloudFront for CDN. Nothing exotic. I can have a working environment provisioned in under a week.
Exactly. And with the AWS startup credits program, we'll have eighteen months of runway before cloud costs become a real budget conversation.
Good. Decision: we go all-in on AWS. Single-cloud strategy. Marc owns the infrastructure setup.
What about the database specifically? I assume Postgres, but let's say it explicitly so new engineers don't have to guess.
Postgres on RDS. Multi-AZ for high availability, automated backups enabled, point-in-time recovery configured. Already scoped last month. pgvector extension available when we need embeddings down the road.
Multi-AZ is the right call. We don't want the database to be a single point of failure on day one of production traffic.
Confirmed then. Decision: Postgres on RDS, multi-AZ, automated backups. Marc owns that setup.
CI/CD? I want to land on a toolchain before we start hiring. New engineers need to hit the ground running.
GitHub Actions. We're already on GitHub, the marketplace has everything we need, and the free tier covers us easily. No extra tooling to maintain, no vendor to manage.
Agreed. Clean, simple. I can set up the initial pipeline — build, lint, test, deploy to ECS — this sprint.
Decision: GitHub Actions for CI/CD. David owns the initial setup.
One more thing on environments. I'd propose three: dev, staging, and production. Staging should be a near-replica of prod — same instance types, same services, different credentials.
Three environments makes sense. Staging on t3 instead of m5 for cost, but same OS, same services, same config structure. No surprises before a deploy.
Good. Anything else on the infrastructure side before we close?
Single-cloud, AWS only. No GCP, no Azure. Simplicity over redundancy at this stage. We revisit only when we hit real scaling constraints. I'll write the ADR this week.
I'll start the Terraform scaffolding today. Should have a working VPC and the first RDS instance up by Thursday.
Perfect. That wraps cloud infrastructure. Good work both of you.